[Music]
so for your information normally we have
this management meeting twice a year and
this but also to sense what are the
problems what are the challenges
brainstorm on the most important topics
so today we we have to be always
sometime
I'm trying to expect the challenges and
the opportunities strategic agenda so
synergies this company is very important
but also to see where the gaps are all
these ideas are going to be harvested in
order to be entered in the world
progress typically mentioned in your
mandate for two reasons the reason I
like to come to GRC I don't get it so
often that I am really superstar and I
come to the meeting so I already feel
encouraged at the beginning of our
meeting and any all right I've been I
think I've been here quite a few times I
think this is my first time and of
course that's a bit of a legacy that
when you can remember that you can
inaugurate it or visitor centers or
we've been at the opening or gallery
which I know is a father of three
children how important it is for
happiness of the families and and life
work balance it's a it's a pleasure to
see that institution prospers develops
and that you had the chance to
contribute a little bit to the to the
greige of the joint research center is
really doing I think Charlene I was very
right I came here on the eve of what
would be very important decision so just
for you to know my last item on the
agenda its
tonight's lunch which will start at 2130
which I hope still to catch in
Strasbourg with my political family just
to make sure that tomorrow we will have
no hiccups and that we can finally start
to work because everybody is ready to
deliver on all the priorities our new
president set out for the whole
Commission for the European Union and I
will come back to them a little bit
later but I can tell you that when we
had our meetings on my future portfolio
and when we've been discussing the
fourth side I was telling her about the
GRC and she is really a moderniser
in how she wants to transform the things
how we adopt the decision that we have
to use more of your scientific evidence
we have to be more anticipatory in a
decision-making that we have to really
transform the way how we adopt the
decision to use the foresight so to be
much more government like if it comes to
reducing the administrative burdens in
in our system and she was very impressed
when I told her that we have almost
3,000 scientists actually working for
the Commission at our five sites and
when I was telling her what you do and
how exciting it is so we would have a
strong support for her and my personal
ambition is to visit you again and this
time with the new president of the
European Commission because I think she
would laugh to see what I know it's here
and some of those labs I'm going to
visit again today just to kind of update
my own knowledge about your latest work
because what was so impressive
when I was here on my previous visits
that I was at that time going from the
lab to the lab and I was asking the
people who've been working in these
laboratories can you tell me are you the
best in the world do you do the world
cried science do you need something from
us to help you to be the best in the
world and I was very much encouraged to
hear from most of our scientists that
what you do here in east bra or at other
sides of the Jersey is cutting-edge
science it's something where we are
excelling as the Europeans and this is
what we need to consolidate improve and
make sure that we'll have more political
relevance and that we are much better
than in the past bring all the European
innovation to the market and to the to
the practical implementation this is
what we need to improve in Europe to
compete in this very dramatic dynamic
and turbulent world we are living in so
I visited he lopat and cows through a
whisper of course so seven is next
because we have high hopes for all the
modeling's and for all the four side
activities which are taking place there
and and you might be assured that you
will have a strong support not only in
me and Kamisha Gabrielle but also big
enthusiastic support coming from the
from the new president also upon the
lion and we'll be working together to
make sure that your work is used much
more in our daily operations and in a
political and legislative work of the
Commission I think that we have to be
much more open and much stronger in
making a good PR about what you do
because some of the things which you do
here are so impressive I remember that
when I was in Argonne Chicago National
Laboratory because I'm trying every
three four years to do such a
technological tour to go to the US to go
to some leading leading scientific
institution there I studied at Stanford
so I'd like to see what's happening at
Silicon Valley but also to visit other
other important countries in the world
just to compare where we Europeans are
standing and I went to this lab and I
visited a smart grid laboratory and I
visited they the Department of Energy
electric vehicle laboratory as well and
then we invited the American friends to
come over here the difference was
enormous
I mean what do you have here is state of
the art and I saw how impressed our
Americans partners have been how we are
testing the electric vehicles what we do
with the smart kids and we show them a
little bit around and I says we don't
have this in Chicago and I said you
right I know because I've been there so
I can really compare it that these are
the things which we have to really work
on because these because you are I would
say that you are giving this great patch
of excellence on what the European Union
means what we do in the Commission and
we have to work more with this
excellence also in how we are dealing
with the with the outside world and I
see it as a part of my job but I was
coming here for the first time in in
2010 I was talking to margot wallström
and she knew your work and she told me
you know what they say about the GRC
said what Marco that this is the best
hidden treasure of the European
Commission
so treasure you are and now we are going
to not only discover you but to promote
you because I think we need the this
positive good story and we need to use
your scientific evidence made work more
in what the Commission has to deliver to
the European people and also to to our
to our Member States I was working with
you and very much I appreciate your
concrete contributions on European
battery alliance I think without your
scientific support we wouldn't be as far
as we are today when I was driving in a
car over here I was just looking through
the through the recent articles which
clearly proves that we are catching up
with our Asian competitors and since we
started to work on the European battery
alliance we managed to to channel more
than 100 billion euros of private
investment into this sector which was
non-existent two years ago when European
karmak has been kind of resigned to
treat the batteries as a commodity which
will buy from Asian competitors and it
took me a while to simply convince them
that it's not the batteries they want to
export to Europe that's eventually after
electric bikes and
trick scooters and electric buses this
would be electric cars which will be
exported from Asia to European Union and
therefore we just simply have to be much
more aware what does it mean strategy
gotta know me what does it mean
technological serenity and we have to be
very very sharp on how we approach these
strategic choices which are which are
ahead of us thanks to your help we did
well and I also would reveal no secret
that we've been working very closely
with our standardization bodies like sin
and sin alike but I would like to ask
you the TRC and maybe we'll have a
chance to talk about it a little bit to
help us to speed up of the work
accelerated as much as possible and to
deliver of new standards of the greenest
the best the most sustainable batteries
on this world I want to ask you for your
help for assistance so we can come up
with the legislative proposals where we
would really carve the standards into
the legislative stone and this would be
the standards of the best batteries in
the world which would be manufactured
but also used in Europe I want to thank
you for all the work you have done for
key performance indicators for the for
the energy Union and I will expand on
that a little bit in a second when I
will be talking about the Green Deal
because you've been also helping us to
work and measure what member states are
delivering the National Energy and
Climate lines and without your input and
contribution we also wouldn't start
another initiative which is becoming as
a spin-off of an energy union bigger and
bigger and this is platform for the coal
regions which we are going to expand
into the regions with heavy industry and
difficult transformation challenges and
which were also supported by what was
again just the idea of using in mind
that we should support this transition
and transformation by the just
transition fund which would be one of
the key tools to deliver to help us to
deliver on a Green Deal and this very
very important
transformation challenges of the future
again
without some of the studies you prepared
for the next economic future for some of
these cold regions in Europe it would be
very difficult for them to start working
to deliver on this very high challenge I
very often refer to the moment which
kind of spur me to think what can we do
for the coal regions and that was the
discussion I had in Katowice with the
local government where I was of course
expecting a bit of tough discussions
with the local leaders because they've
been very much worried what would happen
with all our climate goals and what it
would mean for the local employment and
for the region I was very much surprised
when the president of the local regional
Parliament told me Commissioner please
work with us we need your help because
we do not want to live in the regions
which would be depopulated you do not
want to see any people leaving because
they would simply be in the situation
where they would be worried that the
kids would have respiratory diseases
that there will be no investment coming
they will not get a good job we do not
want to live in their populated areas
and cities help us to bring some new
economic life into this region and this
is exactly what we are doing thanks to
your help with 41 regions across the
Europe and the demand is growing and
your expertise would be needed more than
ever you've been helping us to develop
new approaches have to make our cities
smart what to do with energy efficiency
how to change the building codes to make
sure that we would stop that I would
call it even abuse of energy because we
still and you know it very well
use 40% of our energy in Europe for
heating and cooling of our buildings and
we know that with today's technology we
can do much much better than that and we
have to make it practical usable and
there where science comes with real
policies and and improving the lives of
the people in the city so they can
breathe the cleaner air
can reduce the greenhouse gas emissions
and at the same time we can save on
energy bill so that's I would say
something which is very important and I
know that also for the president from
the line this is very high on her agenda
so I can go on and on about how you
helped me to build the energy Union and
therefore I know that it would be
absolutely instrumental in delivering
these six key priorities which the new
president presented to the European
Parliament and for which she was voted
in as a president-elect and I believe
that tomorrow will be supported by the
majority of MEP zazz a new coach
I saw your program so I know that you
are going to have a detailed discussions
on all six priorities the Green Deal the
economic that works for people Europe
fit for digital age promotion of
European Way of life stronger Europe in
world and push for European democracy if
you allow me I would therefore elaborate
a little bit on what I think should be
kind of chapeau for all of these
priorities and where I very much would
like to use your potential and your
insight and health I think for any
priority for everything we would do in
this new European Commission we have to
have one target one goal in mind what
needs to be done that Europe in 2013
beyond would be one of the top three
economies in the world that's the church
how to make sure we would be not
squeezed out in this huge competition
and pushed aside by China and United
States of America what in our different
areas of responsibility we have to do to
be tough competitor to stand our ground
and to be one of the top three economies
in 2030 and beyond therefore when I was
explaining to the to the new appraises
than how I see Industrial Policy Green
Deal plan
and all the accompanying measures I said
that this is so crucial not only for
that let's say geopolitical position of
the European Commission what kind of
political influence they would have in
the ball which is important and you can
speak for hours have Europe is now the
the good guy to whom a lot of of the
countries are looking up that we have a
big responsibility not only for tackling
the climate change and promote
rules-based system but also for
promoting this fair a fair way of life
but it's very important also for our
internal cohesion in the European Union
simply if we wouldn't be competitive
enough economically strong enough will
we have enough money to provide to keep
up and promote our social model in
Europe we just simply have to see how
our position in the world to be and to
remain one of the tops economy is
important for the social well-being of
our citizens it's as important as that
and I think therefore we have to look at
all the things we do from that
perspective where it would leave the
Europe in 2030 air beyond because what
we do now clearly would have direct
impact on that under this global
positioning of Europe and European Union
in this globalized and dramatically
changing world
therefore what we want to do is to use
already commissioned work problem which
we are working hard to prepare and I
hope that we'll be able to adopt it in
the first half of January and we would
like to already include some foresight
teasers in front of each of the
priorities so why this matters for
Europe why this matters for European
citizens also within this long term
perspective and I also want to to do it
just to kind of prepare the services of
my colleagues commissioners that this
time we should really use the scientific
evidence and all that foresight we have
available for our work for making
sure that what we adopt is future-proof
future-oriented and it's aimed at the
global access that should be our goal if
it comes to the Green Deal priority she
had a couple of brainstorming on on the
Green Deal and I think that we would
have to kind of marry the the big
ambition widget up with the president as
a president-elect presented in the
European Parliament to reduce further
greenhouse gas emissions between 50 to
55 percent with also making sure that
the industry can technologically cope
with that that we would be able to
channel enough funding and financing
into this transformation which is not
easy and that it would have to be a new
way how we would kind of streamline that
go through all the work with the public
authorities do from public procurement
to promote green technologies to
behavioural change and teaching in the
Universities down to and I'm big
supporter of that of also protecting
some of our industries who would have
very difficult life if we would continue
with the policies which I called
manufacture clean and import dirty
simply some of our industries would have
a big problem to to make it like steel
cement aluminum and and we can we can we
can go down the list and their force I
think your great contribution would be
what would be the best way out in a
positive sense protect this European
sensitive sector second and against
carbon leakage I think that carbon
adjustment tax is one of the recipes but
how we should measure it how we should
deal with this issue because when we
know that Europeans dealers can produce
steel with one point six to two tons of
co2 per ton of steel and we know that
Asians producers need three or four
tonnes for making the same ton of steel
and very often over the lower
how can we sustain it in the long run
that we would force our Steelers to
manufacture clean steel and through
public procurement to import dirty one
simply we if we want to be dead serious
about these huge ambitions we have to be
very comprehensive and we have to cover
let's say all the openings which we
which we have which we have there so
Green Deal minimum wage fair pay for men
and women are one of the priorities
which will make it into this first 100
days I think that we are still thinking
how to how to make it most palatable
I forgot also the artificial
intelligence so these are the
initiatives the president announced that
you would like to deliver upon in the
first 100 days I think as I see that
this stage probably will go the first
through the communication to describe
what what is the challenge and what
would be the roadmap and and and and the
planning for later delivery because I
think on many of these things we would
need again your help in proper impact
assessment in measuring in modeling in
making sure that what we for the present
is modern it's up to date and it's
really it's really today to the point
how you'd like to make sure that
foresight is now becoming part of our
daily daily operations first we did
already the mapping of the foresight
capabilities within the Commission
probably you know for me it was a news
that we have 95 units across the
Commission which deal with the foresight
it just the proof that also DG's felt
that this is something new which is
something what we had to use and now I
think we'll have to find a way how to
synergize them how to use the best
people the best output and I would like
to use all that all that information all
that potential which is being built
around you around the GRC and the sector
we need system integrator for force at
it should be you it should be section
for the political guidance and of course
we would be working very closely with
the EPS C for I would say presentational
and priority-setting programming because
they will be of course working very very
close very close with the president so
we need to make sure that within our own
house we know what we do how we use our
potential who does what and to which
priorities we are devoting our our
precious resources and that would be I
would say task for all of us at the
beginning of this of this new Commission
to make sure that that we are running
very very smoothly and we know how to
support each other I'm going to invest a
lot of also my personal efforts to make
sure that you would consolidate what
exists already inter institutionally in
Brussels we have this Espace foresight
networks which generates a lot of
sympathy enthusiasms and you can hardly
see such a harmonious meetings the
European Parliament council Commission
all the committee's IES ECB Court of
Auditors
like in desmos so they are sitting
together discussing how they can
contribute in some kind of pledging
conference type of discussion to the
better for side and to the better
cooperation we have to consolidate it we
have to make sure that this would work
even better in the future and then we
have to go outside I want to create like
EU networks of I call it for myself of
ministries for the future I think we
need just to tell to remember States
about your work about how four sided
anticipatory governance is important and
to have a contact point on the Minister
level in every in every Member States
who would be working with us on these
issues because we can help them a lot
they should know what we do and I
sure that we can also get a lot of very
positive feedback and I also want to set
up the network of the leading foresight
academic institutions or think tanks and
here I would rely on your advice with
whom you work with whom you feel
comfortable
who are these partners were the leading
institutions with which we can join
forces or to whom we can delegate part
of the research which we need to do but
you should be the synergize er of all
that inputs which we'll be getting from
these excellent institutes and of course
the challenge would be how to use all
that information all that knowledge into
what is always a challenge when when we
talk about the science how to make it
practical and politically relevant how
to bringing to the to the 13th floor how
to bring it to the inboxes of my fellow
commissioners how to bring it into the
papers that this would be the headlines
about which the politicians scientists
and think tanks would be would be
discussing and for that a few ideas the
the the first one as I said we will try
to bring these four side teasers already
in the Commission work problem then the
second thing is that we will have
probably the chance to discuss it later
on I would like to discuss with you the
big topics which we should start to work
on to include the most relevant of them
already in the first annual four side
report we should simply establish our
new trademark foresight in the EU being
super relevant and bringing very
important ideas it could be sometimes
what Al Gore called Inconvenient Truth
but we are going to put it on the table
and we are going to generate the
discussion about it I would like to see
the foresight annual report sometimes in
the light spring because I believe and I
will come to that in a second because it
would fit very well in the political
cycle I would like to ask you to think
with me how can we prepare two-pager
three pages
of some kind of horizon scanning most
relevant events or issues or the topics
which we can send every month every
second month you will tell me what is
practical what is feasible is possible
into the inboxes of our Commission so
they would feel part of our efforts and
they would feel informed because the
things you produce things I was reading
before the hearing are super important
and very interesting and they love to
read it but we need to make it in a
concise form and we need to find a way
how to make it attractive for that so
I'd like to discuss with the president
that each month we can have like a few
minutes in the college time devoted to I
would say this horizon scanning of the
most important events that we should
develop some kind of culture of informal
all the informal talks sometimes in the
evening as they call them fireplace
discussions but we can freely discuss
debate what's happening what's next and
really to have to create for us this
this space to think so we can really
legislate legislate better what are the
topics which I was thinking and which I
had discussed preliminary with with our
president should be on our on our
horizon on our other I think I would
very much appreciate your contribution
and your foresight report on the
technological supremacy what we need in
Europe to make sure that it would be
technologically sewer and that we would
have our economic autonomy and that we
would be the relevant player as I said
in a decades to come in which
technologies today we have the upper
hand and what we need to do to
consolidate it in which technologies we
are dramatically lagging behind and what
we need to do to catch up what are the
they are as which are crucial for the
success of European economy and and for
our social model and I believe that this
should be
one of the contributions which we should
be able to hopefully tackle already in
our first annual report I would also
link it with all the challenges which we
tackled so well when you prepared your
piece on artificial intelligence I mean
when you look at other pieces of
information I am receiving recently we
are really at the situation when we are
listening to become digital quality we
have we are know we're in search engines
we are nowhere in browsers we are
exporting our personal data almost
without any control to this American
American Giants we do not control
average the digital space is Russian
Chinese or Americans are and simply we
just have to put these questions on a
table what does it mean for all of us
what does it mean for our economy do we
have enough fuel enough data fuel to be
successful in artificial intelligence
when we cannot like really cover all
these digital digital challenges I'm
sure that you can put many more
questions on this but I just would like
to tell you what would be great
contribution to the European debate if
you help help us to develop the good for
Cedric I think that another big topic
for the Europe would be middle class
what is the future of middle class in
Europe what is demography what are the
skills we need what we simply need to do
to make sure that our advantage which
today is that we have the best workforce
on each planet would remain here what
needs to be done and that's something
which I think it's very important for
the future of the of the of the EU how
should we take up security today it's
not about tanks and cannons because they
are part of it but we see how much
damage you can do through cybercrime
through through the work of intelligence
and how should we make sure that also
these things around the control how can
we bring the world of politicians of
experts and intelligence European
community closer to each other as they
did it in those countries where force
that is playing very important role in
decision-making what needs to be done
that we can talk to each other we can
trust each other and we can really start
to build this new relationship which
would bring us new quality of security
policies and the last topic I would I
would mention would be something which
we should do with the European external
Action Service just to get us closer and
to share and to share our our expertise
how to deal with Africa what shall we do
with raw materials how to best
accommodation do we use our development
aid in a way that it help us to promote
the African and and our interests in
that continent or are we going to
support them and lose every
international competition in Iran system
to Chinese despite the fact that we are
biggest contributor to the development
aid on this planet these are the
questions to which we need not only the
problems but also honest answers what
needs to be done and then of course what
is the preferred scenario how can we
back cast it back to our current job to
what we do today and translate it into
the concrete concrete proposals and
concrete legislative legislative
propositions one more thing about link
with the Member States I think it's it's
crucial and when I saw what you do with
the new concept of resilience how you
develop the dashboard for our Member
States very impressive I think we should
enlarge it we should work closer with
the Member States we should bring the
authorities and they leading think
tankers closer to us and to make this
very very relevant for their policies
but I even would say that once we prove
that this is of a big value maybe to
include it into the new modernized
country specific recommendation and I
don't want to say that we have to go
through all the criteria you are
measuring because it's around 20-plus
but if you have one fact like what I
discovered about my own country Slovakia
the Daeva continue with the current
business model that's all up to 70
percent of the workforce still under the
threat of losing the job by 2030 because
of Technol technology could change
artificial intelligence robot ization
let's that's the fact which every
government should know guys if you do
not think you'll have a big problem and
that's I think the message every Prime
Minister would hear every Minister for
future would like to elaborate on and
this is how we prove that we are very
relevant and useful for you work with us
because we can tackle these issues early
on so coming to the coming to the cycle
how I see it on the ideal world and of
course we'll see how we'll be able to
implement it as I said we are starting
with a commissioned work program
hopefully with a good foresight teaser
we will adopt it we will have country
specific recommendation in in March
then I hope in the later spring we can
come up with our first annual foresight
report which I hope can impact the
discussion of the social partners
European Council in June generate the
public debate and then the president can
reflect how this resonated within the
public opinion in Europe work on some of
the most relevant issues in the State of
the Union speech in autumn and then to
build up on that in the next Commission
work programme and then we would go on
and on and this is how I see we can
embed foresight and your work into the
political cycle and make it relevant for
for what we do in the European Union and
here I believe that the fact that I am
responsible for the programming could
actually help us to use the the insight
which you would do concerning the coming
back to the hidden treasure and to the
to the to the PR I think that what
should be what should be our ambition
here I think it should be very simple we
should strive at global excellence in
four sign that the charsi should be
recognized trademark yeah these guys are
super strong they are doing great job
they managed to link it with political
priorities they are top class foresight
community and I would like the rubble
reports would be so good that we will be
able to bring them to g7 to g20 that we
can have our own panel or a day in Davos
the industrial days in Brussels would
have one day to devote it to the to the
foresight and then we can bring this
foresight community let's say here a
nice prop and to have foresight dates
here in is proud to get the relevant
people Institute's thinkers to come for
two three days over here to have
enlarged management meeting where you
can discuss the high quality work which
we'll be doing in the fore side and to
and to establish ourselves on this on
this global market and to show that we
mean business and actually we do it we
do it very very well so this is just a
couple of the ideas I got excellent
script for my speech but as I'm sure
you're feeling right now I kind of
departed from that and and because I
wanted to tell you something from from
my heart something very very personal
and just to conclude I just really would
like to tell you that we'll be working
very closely with Maria Gabrielle we are
currently like a duo on this digital
world because I was also replacing vice
president an seat for the last few
months of our Monday since he became the
member of the European Parliament we'll
be working very closely with all the
vice president's commissioners and I
just would like to write it once again
the new president is very much motivated
and interested in working with you and
establish this new anticipatory
governance moderner legislating and
foresight capabilities of the of the
European Commission so I'm very much
looking forward to our continuation of
our work because I think that I never
left you
the guardare is still here the join
research center is there I see some
familiar faces so I believe that it
would be just the continuation of the
great relationship and I'd like to thank
for that then and just to show you how
much I'm looking forward to the next
Monday thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we are there to take you specifically
mentioned the geopolitical type of
commission that we serve also to ensure
that there is a monitored performance
and monitor trouble think about well
accompany transition and you mentioned
well there it would be a good example
about the college so metric models for
example that are implemented and run by
this house and we are also and achieving
the strategic objectives of this
commission so many thanks it was really
liberating and very much encouraging
thank you to anyone that really must ask
the question though it is not planned
before we have a way forward
[Applause]
that charlena has asked me to share with
you a brute presentation about DVD
understand see developing up to now
states in our society and all the money
train activities